apple is a bit larger today
than the company created by steve jobs
in his parents garage
facebook is about putting power in
people's hands
getting access to information is an
important human right the chief
executives of
apple facebook and alphabet are
congressional hearings veterans
they'll be joined by first-timer amazon
ceo
jeff bezos on wednesday as all four come
virtually before a house judiciary
subcommittee
the topic this time is one that strikes
at the heart of each of their companies
whether new laws are needed to rein in
big tech
this is an unusual moment when we've got
the ceos
of four of the five largest companies in
america
showing up at a hearing at the same time
testifying in a hostile environment
about how they became so large
and whether they acquired their dominant
position in the market legally
the bipartisan investigation is looking
at whether u.s anti-trust laws
need to be updated these online
platforms are in some ways a new
phenomenon certainly knew
enough that they didn't exist when u.s
antitrust laws which are decades old
were written some lawmakers say the tech
giants are wielding
excessive power over markets such as
online retail
online advertising and smartphone apps
amazon dominates online retail with
nearly 40 percent of u.s
online shopping occurring on its
platform amazon with a market value of
about 1.5
trillion dollars is facing scrutiny over
whether it unfairly uses its size and
platform against competitors and other
sellers on its site
jeff bezos amazon's ceo came under
pressure to testify to congress after
the wall street journal reported in
april
that amazon was using data from its own
sellers
to launch competing products amazon says
it strictly prohibits its employees from
using seller data to determine which
private label products to launch
wednesday's hearing will be the first
time the world's richest man testifies
before congress
it will be a new experience for him and
it'll be interesting to see how he
responds
lawmakers are expected to challenge
amazon's contention that its business
practices
don't drown out competitors bezos in the
opening statement he released says
amazon accounts for less than four
percent of retail in the u.s
and unlike industries that are
winner-take-all there's room in retail
for many winners
bezos's testimony comes as the federal
trade commission along with some states
is probing whether amazon's practices
hurt competition
apple's ceo tim cook is expected to
defend how his company's app store
operates
it generates about 15 billion dollars in
annual sales for apple
developers customers and lawmakers are
balking at the 30 percent cut the
company takes on sales
it's the only app store available on
more than 900 million iphones worldwide
apple has argued that it's not a
monopolist and a study at commissioned
ahead of wednesday's hearing says the 30
fee is fair and similar to other digital
marketplaces
mr cook is set to tell lawmakers apple
does not have a dominant market share
in any market where we do business i am
proud
to represent apple before you today tim
cook has appeared before congress before
back in 2013 it's about apple's tax
practices
can you understand there's a perception
of unfair advantage here
mr cook sir i see this is a very complex
topic that is not an easy place to
testify and he kept his cool for
almost two hours in that forum i'm
committed to being fully transparent
including with policy makers
cindar pichai the ceo of google's parent
company alphabet
testifies as his company faces a
potential anti-trust lawsuit from the
u.s
justice department in a group of states
their focus is on google's ad business
google has repeatedly denied that it
runs its business in an anti-competitive
manner mr pachai plans to say that
because of his company's tools
businesses on main street can compete in
a way that wasn't possible 20 years ago
including globally but critics say the
company uses its dominance in search
to stifle competition the stakes are
high for google in this hearing although
they may not get the most
questions they are facing the most
advanced
antitrust investigation of the four
firms we expect
the u.s regulators to file a lawsuit
potentially as early as this summer
against google and so what mr pachai
says could factor into that
and he's going to have to be on his
guard
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg is also
expected to face questions about his
company's dominance along with google
of the us digital advertising market mr
zuckerberg is the youngest of the four
ceos to testify but he's actually
testified
more than the other three men he's been
there three times in the last few years
i recognize that we play an important
role in society and have unique
responsibilities because of that
he's becoming quite practiced at this
nevertheless the stakes are high for
facebook
facebook owned platforms including
instagram and whatsapp have more than
2.5 billion users worldwide
some critics of the company are calling
for facebook to be forced to divest
instagram and whatsapp mr zuckerberg
plans to tell the subcommittee
at facebook we compete hard because
we're up against other smart and
innovative companies that
are determined to win
the four tech titans appear to be on the
same page arguing their companies
innovate and don't unfairly dominate
it's hard to say that this hearing will
lead to
specific outcomes on its own like a
change in the law
or an antitrust case against these
companies
but these hearings do matter in the
court of public opinion
and whether the ceos handle themselves
well and defend themselves well
will be important for how their
companies are perceived and
how the next administration whoever it
is approaches them
you